non-minimalists
when you talk about jealousy can you
have any examples you'd be comfortable
sharing or maybe even a little
uncomfortable with sharing
sure about times where you felt jealous
in the past and how that sort of
rose within you i think it was a huge uh
contributing factor to my eating
disorders i think you know being jealous
of other people's bodies and thinking
well
why can't mine look that way and does my
body
negatively impact my career it's you
know very conventional for
actresses to be very thin and
i would you know certainly have a lot of
jealousy slash envy
toward those examples and then one one
other example that i don't want to
tread on too much because i've talked
about it a bit but
and you know from the one woman show
ryan but my co-star was ariana grande
who's
biggest you know at this time she was
skyrocketing to be the biggest pop star
and i being in the presence of her
consistently
made me feel inadequate and and i would
feel jealous of well why does she get
all these opportunities
why am i not getting the same
opportunities we're on the same show
where it's not even like
you know like one of us is more maine
than the other it's a two-hander show
like why am i not getting the same
opportunities
even though she was pursuing pop music
which is a thing that i would never
want to pursue like it didn't even
logically i could go well this doesn't
make sense to be comparing myself to
this person
maybe it makes more sense to be
comparing myself to somebody who had
wanted to write and direct some you know
up-and-coming young filmmaker or
something like that
so i would try and uh intellectualize
the emotion which was also making it
worse
because it wasn't just allowing myself
to feel it yes i wouldn't just go
i feel this it's okay you're okay and
then
you know doing the work doing the self
work instead i would try and
intellectualize and think that somehow
that was like
helping me but it was not at all yeah
because now you're telling yourself you
shouldn't have that expression
right right and then also you're adding
another layer on here
you know what here's the problem i
should compare myself with
another person not the person i'm
comparing myself with
not realizing that the comparison is
actually the thing that's creating the
emotion
yeah exactly exactly yeah did you enjoy
this video
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists today
your support keeps our podcast and
youtube channel 100
advertisement free